ein spaziergänger findet eine
skelettierten menschlichen schädel und
weitere knochen so geschehen am zweiten
mai in einem waldstück bei berg tal in
der nähe von ingolstadt bei
anschließenden grabungen entdeckt die
polizei einen zweiten schädel und noch
merkel noch das erdreich wird untersucht
szene und weitere knochenteile kommen
zum vorschein das ergebnis die beiden
leichen bei den beiden leichen handelt
es sich um ein seit 18 jahren vermisst
das paar darüber bonn besprechen mit
meinem kollegen karl kai mähr ist mir
zugeschaltet aus unserer münchner
redaktion karl seit 18 jahren diese
leichen entdeckt dort in einem waldstück
bei ingolstadt wie konnte das passieren
ja wie so üblich in solchen langen
vermisstenfällen sind es dann
spaziergänger oder sportler oder gassi
geher die dann solche grausigen
entdeckungen machen das kommt relativ
oft vor die beiden und lagen sehr
abgelegen in einem waldstück und man
muss dazu sagen sie sind seit 2002 weg
damals waren die technischen
voraussetzungen der polizei andere als
heute waren wenn dann beispielsweise ein
handy ausgeschaltet ist und es gibt
keine heiße spur von irgendjemanden dann
ist es schwierig da dann dieser leichen
zu finden es gab allerdings 2009 schon
einmal einen hinweis von einem
informanten der die polizei darüber
informiert hat dass die beiden leichen
in einem friedhof in ingolstadt in ein
offenes grab gelegt worden sein sollen
wo am nächsten tag eine beerdigung
stattfinden sollte das hat dann die
polizei überprüfte und konnte aber da
keine doppelbelegung feststellen wissen
wir
um wen es sich bei diesem pärchen
handelt ja es handelt sich um ein
liebespaar sabine und ihren freund eugen
man weiß etwas mehr über sabine sieber
angehende zahnarzthelferin hat ihre
ausbildung auch fertig gemacht und hat
dann in einem großhandel gearbeitet ist
dort aber rausgeflogen weil sie mit
drogen am steuer erwischt wurde
es ist bekannt seit wann sie dann
verschwunden sind die beiden waren noch
gemeinsam essen waren danach noch in der
wohnung eines freundes im ingolstädter
nordosten dort wurden sie dann auch
zuletzt gesehen wie sie mit gepackten
mit einem gepackten rucksack die wohnung
verlassen haben sollen
der bruder sabines bruder alarmierte
dann die polizei weil sie weniger tage
später nicht zu seiner geburtstagsfeier
gekommen waren
und wir werden jetzt die ermittlungen ab
laufen in diesem fall die ermittlungen
laufen natürlich sehr sehr hoch wenn
dich ab man muss sich jetzt vorstellen
nach 18 jahren leichenteile in einem
wald das war damals schon ein prozess
der riesengroß war die kriminalpolizei
ingolstadt wurde unterstützt von der
bereitschaftspolizei man hat erde in
einer halle gesiebt so sind dann zähne
beispielsweise und auch andere knochen
zum tageslicht gekommen und jetzt ist
die spannende frage sind die beiden
einem verbrechen zum opfer gefallen
jetzt liegt natürlich der verdacht nahe
bei grabungen gefunden wie gesagt hat
man sich selbst umbringt ist natürlich
schwierig sich danach selbst unter die
erde zu bringen oder sich selbst zu
vergraben die spannende frage ist jetzt
kommt dass durch die vegetation oder
wohnen sie wirklich opfer eines
verbrechens darüber kann dann aus
aufschluss geben ist der kopf zum
beispiel eingeschlagen oder gibt es dort
irgendwie noch pistolen pistolenmunition
die da irgendwie noch alle die dort an
den kopf stecken oder irgendwie sowas
darüber das gilt es jetzt herauszufinden
es gab schon mal hinweise dass die opfer
eines verbrechens geworden sein sollen
damals haben vier leute aus der drehung
aus der drogenszene der polizei gesagt
die beiden sollen umgebracht worden sein
bei eugen schulden in der drogenszene
hatten den dort waren beide sehr sehr
tief drin